welcome back in michigan covent 19 put  the legal system on hold the state's  largest  county postponed jury trials until  january because of surging infections  the number of chronovirus patients in  u.s hospitals has topped  50 thousand that is the highest level in  nearly three months  daily infections are rising in all but  three states right now  with the surge most severe in the  midwest and the southwest  europe is also experiencing a deadly  wave of infections  the world health organization confirms a  72 percent  jump in cases in italy last week and  pope francis is now urging  followers to obey health recommendations